NARRATOR:
This is the Shark Tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes
of getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
I'm asking for $150,000...
...For 30% of my company.
NARRATOR: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
Someone wants
to come after my business
and take the food out of
my kids' mouths, I will fight!
I started this company
'cause I was --
I was diagnosed with skin cancer
at 26.
[ voice breaking ] I know
I am just starting, but...
This is my passion.
I haven't have any food
for eight days.
You are so full of crap!
I don't get you.
CUBAN:
You're the one who told us
you know your company
inside and out.
We have sold
a half a million of these.
Wow!
what?!
NARRATOR:
If the sharks hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money.
I want to give you
an opportunity.
NARRATOR: And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
O'LEARY:
I'll give you $75,000.
I want a royalty of 7%.
I say I give you the $150,000,
and we tell this bozo
to take a walk.
Ohh!
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin o'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu,
with over $6 billion
in retail sales to date.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents and
has launched over 300 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas mavericks.
[ birds chirping ]
We have to put on our sunscreen.
we got to be sun-safe.
I'm Betsy Johnson. I live
in prairie village, Kansas,
with my amazing husband, Matt,
and my adorable son, Andy.
Do you want to go outside?
Time for a walk!
I was diagnosed with skin cancer
at 26.
And it was actually
one of the scariest things
that ever happened to me.
I quickly learned
that one bad sunburn
can really affect people
for the rest of their lives.
So I decided that I wanted
to start a business
to keep everybody sun-safe.
JOHNSON: Hey, Ber!
hi, Bets! How's it going?
It can be a bit of a struggle,
because he lives in Pittsburgh.
Thankfully, for the internet,
it makes it possible
for Berry and I
to be in the same room.
I know
that we're gonna be big.
Berry has reservations
about coming on "Shark Tank,"
because he thinks
we can do it on our own
without giving up
any of our company.
But I feel
we don't have the experience
and the business connections
like the sharks.
If we don't get a deal
with the sharks,
I don't think
our business can grow as big
as it actually could be.
Hi, sharks. I'm Betsy Johnson.
And I'm Berry wanless.
BOTH: And we are the siblings
behind Swimzip...
A sun-protective
swimwear line.
WANLESS: We're seeking $60,000
for a 5% stake in Swimzip.
JOHNSON: As parents,
we want to keep our babies safe
and protected
from the sun's harmful rays.
No matter how diligently
we apply and reapply sunscreen,
we are still subjecting
our children's skin
to the harsh sun and
potentially painful sunburns.
Taking kids to the pool
and beach should be fun,
but with all the screaming
and fighting and fussing,
traditional sun-protective
methods are such a chore.
There has to be
a better way.
You got it!
there has to be
a better way.
Let us introduce you
to the super-stylish
U.V.-protective swimwear line
that keeps kids sun-safe
and parents sane.
Swimzip features
our signature full-length zipper
down the front,
so it's extremely easy
to put on and take off.
And both our tops
and our bottoms
block 98% of U.V.A.
and U.V.B. cancer-causing rays.
In fact, Swimzip's
sun-protective swimwear
is so simple to put on,
kids can literally
do it themselves.
Just one quick zip
leads to a day
full of
easy sun protection.
wow!
good job!
All right, sharks,
who wants to zip up this deal?
Are you designing and
manufacturing all of this today?
Yep. I do
all the designs myself.
We create all the prints.
We work directly
with the manufacturer.
It's very stylish.
I love the little stuff.
Really quick,
we got samples for you, so...
GREINER:
oh, great. Great.
Totally.
Yeah.
thanks.
GREINER:
thank you.
JOHN: Thank you.
Is this an adult-size?
No. It's actually
the kid-size.
Thanks, bud.
Our swimsuits
actually come as sets,
so you get
both a top and a bottom
when you purchase
our product.
Wave bye!
say thanks!
HERJAVEC:
See you guys!
Bye, guys!
What are your sales?
We sold $225,000
this year.
HERJAVEC:
Was that your first year?
That's our third year
in business.
Third year. What were the sales
the second year?
The second year, $18,000,
so we've grown 1,100%.
How are you selling them?
We sell on Amazon.
We sell on our website.
We also sell
on the target website.
in high-end hotels.
JOHN: You're selling
to the independent stores?
Yeah.
It's fairly small, right?
It is fairly small
right now.
We have stores that sell
in Japan, Germany, Guam.
What are you
making it for?
$5 to $7.
O'LEARY:
What were your profits?
$100,000.
But you didn't pay yourselves
anything, right?
We currently
don't take a salary.
O'LEARY:
So, you've basically told me
it's worth $1.2 million.
You're offering me 5%
for $60,000, right?
Mm-hmm.
You're making $100,000
without paying yourselves.
If you each paid yourself
$50,000,
which is not unreasonable,
you make nothing.
This year, yes.
Is there anything unique about
the materials that you're using?
Nope.
It's swimsuit material.
HERJAVEC:
the material is not unique.
What makes you unique
is the fact that you have
that same material
with a zipper up the front.
That's it.
No.
Well, that's part of it.
What really sets it apart
are our designs.
Betsy designs
all of these suits herself.
But where we really come in
is that our price point
is $15 wholesale,
top and bottom.
The people who we're
competing with are $45 to $60.
Without a zipper.
We're trying to get at what
this business is really worth.
I think because you've
established some market share
and you've proven you can
design it -- I don't know --
I'd put a value on it
of half a million bucks, maybe,
but it's not worth
$1.2 million.
Let's ask our Fubu
retail clothing guy.
Can I set this up myself
for $500,000?
Yes.
So, what do
I need you for?
I look at my money
as gasoline.
I want to pour it
on something
that I already understand
how it works.
I just add money. I make
more money. That's what I love.
There's no place
for me to pour my money into.
I don't see it here.
I'm out.
We are
on the target website,
and we actually have
an exclusive line for them.
They have not taken you
into the stores yet?
No. We're trying to work
right now to do a test
in the Southern stores.
JOHN:
you don't want to do that.
Why not?
The big guys and girls
can crush you
with just
one set of returns.
Yeah.
Their margins
are so, so small.
You want to stay where you are,
with the boutiques.
But that's
part of the problem here.
You're a little green
in understanding all this.
Now, I have to
take my hat off to you.
You made it past
the hardest point --
to show proof of concept.
well -- yeah.
But there's bad stuff
coming.
It's a tough one for me, because
I see the growth potential here.
It's just a little too early
for me, so I'm out.
JOHNSON:
I started this company
'cause I was diagnosed
with skin cancer at 26.
[ voice breaking ]
and, you know...
I had insurance
and a paycheck...
And quit.
I decided to try to take
this on, and this is my passion.
Like, I know this company
and sun protection
is the wave of the future,
and we're starting
with swimwear.
And, you know,
I still have a lot to learn.
But I'm a fighter,
and I will build this brand,
and I will build this swimwear
to be the best swimwear line
that kids can have.
I'm a mommy on a mission.
My 1-year-old is just --
he is my world.
And we go to the park,
and he wears his Swimzips,
because I can't find anything.
I am pushing this product.
I know I am just starting,
and I have made mistakes,
but we will bring this company
to something huge.
And, you know, I just --
i-i don't think you understand.
We're just at the tip
of the iceberg here.
$225,000 sales is nothing
to laugh at by -- by any means.
And I think Daymond's right --
you are green.
But, you know, frankly,
all of us up here,
if we knew the things we should
be afraid of in business,
we may have never started.
[ laughs ]
Right?
Yeah, that's true.
And what is really apparent
about you and you, Berry,
is that, you know,
the best way to get over
doubt and inexperience
is simply action.
I'm just struggling with,
how do you go
from a little boutique business
to millions of dollars?
I don't have the answer.
And because
I don't see the answer,
I'm not gonna give you
my money today.
I'm out.
Betsy, you're a beast.
Thanks.
and that's
an enormous compliment.
Berry, you're there to help her,
and that's a great thing.
But you're still
a family business.
And family businesses aren't
to the point of their life cycle
where they can just explode.
You haven't even broken out
of the "I'm hiring my friends
and family" mode yet.
Then you get to 10 employees
or 15 employees.
Then you have to manage
those employees, right?
It's just a huge step.
and until you get to that step,
it's much more difficult
to be ignited
and to have
that inflection point.
And honestly,
I learned a lot of lessons
from the 30 companies
I've invested in on "Shark Tank"
that proved that point to me.
Well, I want
a strategic investor.
I don't want to be
a family business.
Like I said, I want this
out there, and I need the help.
I'm out.
Okay, we have one shark left.
Lori?
You know, I was a one-man band
for five years.
I had passion and drive
and a dream, and I made it.
I'm sitting here today.
JOHNSON: Yeah.
I see so much of that
in you.
Thank you.
Because you are not only smart,
you're right on trend,
because melanoma is
one of the number-one killers.
Yeah.
And it starts in children.
So...
...I want to give you
an opportunity here,
because I believe in you.
So, I'm going to give you
the $60,000
for a 20% equity stake.
I personally want you
to be open to going into target
and other places,
but we're just going to ask
for terms that don't hurt us.
I love that.
so, no returns.
You're --
see, this is what I need,
is I need the experience,
and you've done it.
Well, you're doing really well
yourself,
and that's why
I want to get behind you --
because sometimes, you just
have to get behind people
that are doing
the right thing.
thank you.
So, that's my offer.
That's evaluation of you
at $300,000.
That's fair.
Because you don't make
any money.
I think it's too low.
You know what, Lori?
Would you be willing
to do $120,000 for 20%?
Ohh!
NARRATOR:
Four sharks are out.
Betsy and Berry
have an offer from Lori --
$60,000
for 20% of their company --
but they have made
a counteroffer,
surprising the sharks.
You know what, Lori?
Would you be willing
to do $120,000 for 20%?
Ohh!
We were at $60,000 for 20%.
CUBAN: Dang!
So --
I had a lot of confidence in you
four or five minutes ago.
It's your drive, your passion,
that hard work,
what I think you can do.
But now
I'm getting worried,
because you're showing me
a different side.
You have to
gain my confidence back now.
I'm not going to change my
number, but I want to make sure
that I've just picked
the right person.
Well, I do believe in it.
I just want to -- I want to
make sure I have enough capital.
CUBAN: You're the one
who came in that asked for
a specific amount of money.
You're the one who
told us you know your
company inside and out.
You're the one who told us
you only need the expertise.
we value at five-times sales,
and she's devaluing
our company,
and I believe
that it's worth that.
yeah, but, Betsy,
hang on a second.
[ sharks arguing ]
100% of nothing
is still nothing!
you make no money!
You have no paycheck.
We need this deal.
JOHN: Berry,
why aren't you saying much?
Why are you so hesitant?
'cause I think I'm the reason
that she's not saying yes.
Why? Why not?
why isn't she
saying yes?
Because I believe
in our company.
I think we are gonna be
a $5 million company.
And if we're giving someone
this 20% stake right now,
it's a huge, huge part
of our business.
I don't want to push you
into anything.
If you're not comfortable
with this deal, don't take it.
I'm taking a chance on you
because I believed in you.
A bigger chance, now,
than you thought.
This is about money.
make a decision.
What do you want to do?
Let's try it.
Okay.
All right.
Lori, you have a deal!
Oh. All right. Good.
[ laughs ]
[ sighs ]
Berry, you have to get
on the train.
let's do this!
I'm on the train.
all right.
good. Good.
Bye. Thank you.
HERJAVEC:
Good luck, guys.
Berry, ask for a paycheck.
We got it! Yes!
Lori,
we are gonna do this!
WANLESS: I think I was
a little hesitant at first
because we do
value our company a lot
and we do anticipate
huge sales.
But I do think,
at the end of the day,
it was the right deal
and that Lori's gonna be
fantastic, a fantastic partner.
We're really excited
about that.
NARRATOR: In season 2,
Kimberly Nelson made a deal
with Barbara Corcoran
for her homemade-cake business,
Daisy Cakes.
What do you think?
Do we have a deal?
Of course.
Whew!
Let's see what she's doing now.
Daisy Cakes has gone through
some major changes
since my last update.
On my last update, we moved
all the baking out of state
to a large-production bakery.
It seemed like the only way
to meet the demand
and keep my customers happy.
For a few months,
everything was good.
And then things just started
to spiral downward.
We made a couple
of really poor hiring decisions,
and the quality of the cakes
was so bad,
we lost nearly $150,000
in bad product.
The worst part is,
that damaged our reputation
with our most loyal customers.
We take a lot of pride
in these Daisy Cakes
being made the right way.
So, with some really good
words of advice from Barbara,
we decided to bring
the Daisy Cakes baking back here
to Pauline, South Carolina,
where it started.
So, how are y'all doing
on these? You got enough?
We're back to basics here,
and I've hired
a great team of employees.
And I learned
a really big lesson --
that's that nobody's gonna make
a Daisy cake
the way my mom and I
are gonna make a Daisy cake.
CORCORAN: I knew I'd be
finding you hard at work!
Come on!
show me the operation!
oh, my God!
Barbara has been
a tremendous support,
and her guidance has been just
what we needed for Daisy Cakes.
Our projected sales
for Daisy Cakes
over the next year
should be close to $3 million.
Let me tell you something.
we're just getting started.
CORCORAN:
When you're growing a business,
it's a series of mistakes that
you have to learn to overcome.
Kim has the magic ingredient
of every great entrepreneur.
When she gets hit,
she pops right back up.
And that's why Kim is succeeding
again at Daisy Cakes.
NELSON: Just because
you get a deal on "Shark Tank"
doesn't mean
it's going to be an easy road.
But with Barbara by my side,
I know the future
for Daisy Cakes has no limits.
NARRATOR: Next into the tank
is an accomplished entrepreneur
from San Diego, California,
with a simple way to stay fit.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Phil Black,
and my company is Fitdeck.
And I'm seeking $300,000
in exchange
for 20% of the company.
Fitdeck is a custom deck
of fitness playing cards
that makes exercise more simple,
convenient, and fun.
Each card has an illustration
and instructions
on how to perform the exercise.
So all you need to do
is shuffle, deal, and go.
Can we see a package?
Sure.
And where are you
selling them?
Primarily from our website,
direct to consumer.
That's about 75%
of our business.
So, why don't you take
Fitdeck body weight?
HERJAVEC: Thank you.
This is cross training,
Daymond,
thank you.
our equivalent to crossfit.
Thank you.
And, of course, mark --
Fitdeck basketball.
Appreciate that.
So, sharks,
who's ready to go all-in?
HERJAVEC: Okay,
walk me through a single unit.
What do you sell it for?
what does it cost to make?
That sells for $14.95
on our website.
It costs about $2 to make.
Are you selling
a lot of these cards right now?
We have sold a half a million
of these Fitdecks.
Wow!
what?!
in how long
a period of time?
That's been
over the last seven years or so.
Ohh.
the majority of those have been
in the last four years or so.
Well, how many
did you sell last year?
Last year,
we sold 55,000.
So, how many dollars
is that?
Last year, $640,000.
Very impressive.
what was your profit?
Last year,
the profit was a break-even.
Why? How could you
only break even?
HERJAVEC:
there's something missing.
You got to be making
a ton of money.
Or you got screwed
somewhere along the line.
Well, last year
was an anomaly.
The prior years, we had
an average of $725,000 in sales
with an average profit
of about $120,000.
So, when your sales dropped,
your profit was wiped out?
Correct.
Okay. So, Phil, here's where
it doesn't add up for me.
Let's assume you did $700,000
two years ago in sales.
Your cost of goods on that
would've been $100,000, right?
That leaves you
with $600,000.
You made $100,000.
that leaves you with $500,000.
You're spending $500,000
running a $700,000 company?
Where's the money going?
To some r&d --
we have to create them.
It's going to making videos.
we made 100 videos last year.
We redid the entire website.
O'LEARY: Phil, my greatest fear
for this content
is that when it moves online
or into an app,
it's simply free.
I mean, if you just Google
these stretches,
there's a ton of content
that's there for free.
Well, the problem with that is
it's so all over the place
that if you wanted to do it --
you could type in
"stretching exercises
for a bad hamstring" --
you're gonna get
15 million responses.
And we're breaking it down
for you to make it very simple.
What would you like
the $300,000 for?
The $300,000 is gonna amount
to where we think
the future of the business is.
So 75% to 80% of that, we feel
is going on the digital side.
You're planning
to sell that app?
correct.
CUBAN:
that's a tough business.
we've been selling that app
for the last --
that's a very tough space.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
you've been selling --
you have an app?
We've been selling it
for about four or five months.
We're getting
1,000 downloads a month
with very little marketing.
It's all free
at that point, right?
No, we sell this
for $9.99.
How did you come up with this?
tell us about your background.
I was a Navy Seal
for almost six years.
CUBAN: You were?
yes.
Oh! All right. Thank you.
good for you.
Yeah, well, actually,
the idea for Fitdeck
was based on a card game that I
played with my college roommates
at Yale University.
And it was a game called "pug,"
short for "push-up game."
now, this became
a campus-wide sensation at Yale.
You know,
it made an impression on me.
I graduated from Yale,
and I went to one of the biggest
investment banks in the world
for about 2 1/2 years.
Which bank was it, Phil?
It was Goldman Sachs.
no kidding.
Ah!
oh, my God.
so, hang on. Hang on.
You -- you have a degree
from Yale.
You were an investment banker,
and that wasn't enough,
so then
you were a Navy Seal.
I came to my senses after
the investment banking
and became a seal.
So, now you're flying around
the world doing crazy stuff.
HERJAVEC:
okay, and then what happened?
Well, while I was flying
around the world,
we had every fitness product
and program in the world
at our fingertips,
and guess what we played.
Pug?
we played the pug game!
I left, and I went
to Harvard business school.
And there --
[ laughter ]
HERJAVEC: Okay! Stop!
All that training --
you came up with cards?!
Exactly!
So, finish the story.
So, I said,
"why stop at push-ups?
"why not take this pug concept
and create a business
out of it -- Fitdeck?"
we can attack all things --
not just body-weight exercises,
but yoga, pilates, stretching,
crossfit, basketball.
HERJAVEC:
how old are you?!
Are you like 58? How could
you have time to do all that?
I'm 43.
most of this was done --
I have four kids, too, so they
keep me pretty busy, as well.
[ laughs ]
and a dog.
Phil, it's, like,
a heck of a story, but...
Why cards?
cards?!
trading cards, you know?
Why the cards?
it just doesn't add up.
I-i-i-it's a simple solution.
You understand the idea
of milking it now...
Yes.
if you've already got
the infrastructure.
I don't know
how long this lasts,
but you could probably pull a
couple million bucks out of it.
That's what I'm hoping to do,
Kevin. That's why I'm here.
CUBAN:
Phil, it's interesting.
Honestly, with your background,
it's kind of a disconnect
that you go from there
to trading cards,
but you've done
a great job of it.
To sell 4 million,
that's amazing.
What is a problem
is you recognize
you're gonna have to go
into the mobile side of things.
Yes.
It is the most brutal business
in the world.
There are
hundreds of thousands of apps,
and probably hundreds
of thousands minus 1,000
have gone out of business.
I just don't see that
as being an equitable outcome.
[ chuckles ] Right? I just
don't see the future there.
And so, for that reason,
I'm out.
Phil, you're an m.B.A.
investment banker
at Goldman Sachs.
Yale/Harvard graduate.
You've put a value on
this business of $1.5 million.
Come on! I mean, you know
it's not worth $1.5 million now.
It doesn't make enough money
to value that.
Well, I think it does.
I think we have
a great library of content,
I get that, but you --
40 different titles.
We've got cash flow.
We have a great name --
Fitdeck, fitness deck.
It's a great name.
We have the story. We have
authenticity. We have a brand.
And you're a Navy Seal!
Exactly!
And lastly, if there's one thing
that I think all of us share...
What?
...We can fight.
Robert,
I know you can fight.
Lori, I know you can fight.
Kevin, I know you can fight.
Daymond, I know can fight.
Is anyone gonna argue
that Mark Cuban can fight?
Guess what --
I can fight, too!
yeah, but I fight for me.
I can fight for me.
I can fight for you!
I ain't fighting for you.
Someone wants to
come after my business, Kevin,
and take the food out of
my kids' mouths, I will fight!
whoa.
Whoo!
you guys want to join me?
we'll all fight!
Phil, do you --
[ laughter ]
Somebody
pepper-spray this guy.
Do you do this --
do you do this full time?
Yes. This is
our primary source of income.
Fitdeck must work.
I've got four kids.
JOHN: Phil, let me bring
some clarity.
okay.
You know, Goldman Sachs,
Harvard, Yale, a seal, Fitdeck.
I'm so impressed,
I probably want to do the
deal just 'cause of you.
I probably will get a financial
advisor, a Professor,
a bodyguard, and a trainer
all at the same time.
All right!
[ laughter ]
um, you know,
it's amazing.
But, you know, applications --
it's the new gold rush.
Everybody with a computer
believes they have one.
You know, the money you have to
spend to keep this current,
I just don't know if I can help
you and I think it's worth it.
You have a --
I -- [ sighs ]
I'm out.
Phil, I'm with you
on the cards.
It's a pretty good idea.
Where you and I digress
is there's something wrong
in the business.
You're selling 700,000
for a product where your margin
is unbelievable,
and you can't make money
at it.
Very impressive story.
thank you for your service.
But I'm out.
You -- as a technology person,
you know,
the fact that we have
500,000 decks out there,
that we can move people over
and migrate them --
Phil, if you think
they're gonna migrate,
you're lying to yourself.
You know, Phil,
I think you're amazing.
I love your passion.
I like the simplicity
of the card,
because, sometimes,
I think we get too device-y.
But I think
it's really difficult
to compete
in this market.
When you go online,
there's just so many
different offerings
for exercises.
For me, I don't think it's
the right business to invest in.
So I'm out.
HERJAVEC:
who's left?
I think
Mr. Wonderful is the last,
and I got to tell you
something, Phil.
I've been sitting in the
Shark Tank for many years now,
listening
to a lot of pitches,
and I pretty well get it
very quickly.
I don't get you.
Phil, your răšsumăš
is very impressive --
perhaps the best we've ever seen
on "Shark Tank."
I'm not kidding.
It does not equate
to a deck of cards.
You are destined for
much greater things than this.
I'm giving you a free pass
to come back through the doors
with the next idea,
and I think everybody else here
would do the same.
This is not it.
I'm out.
Phil, thanks.
Thank you
for your time, Phil.
thank you.
It's a pleasure
to meet you.
Thank you. Likewise.
GREINER:
nice to meet you.
They weren't really
buying into the vision
and into the business,
and as a Navy Seal, I've swum
with real sharks before.
And given the choice,
I'd probably go back
to the real sharks
and stay away from those guys.
NARRATOR: Next up
is an entrepreneur with a pill
that he feels everyone
should have just in case.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Daryl Stevenett,
and I've created a product
called Life Caps.
I'm here
seeking a $200,000 investment
in exchange
for 30% of my company.
Now, sharks,
can I ask you a question?
Do I look healthy?
Do I look mentally alert?
I haven't had any food
for eight days.
[ chuckles ]
Life caps is
a life-saving survival pill
that you can take
in times of emergency
when food is not available.
Life caps satisfies hunger.
I am not hungry.
Life caps provides nutrition.
I am mentally alert.
I got the idea a few years ago
when I saw a story
about coal miners
that were trapped underground
in Southern Utah.
The rescue workers were drilling
a 4-inch hole down 1,500 feet,
trying to get food and water
down to the miners.
Then I thought, "why doesn't
somebody come up with an idea
like a pill that could
sustain life in an emergency?"
then I thought, "why not me?"
I'm a musician.
I knew nothing about
formulating a food product,
so I reached out to a friend
of mine who had created
some of the top-selling
energy bars in America.
And a few weeks later,
Life Caps was born.
Life caps is perfect
for any emergency situation,
such as earthquakes,
tornados, hurricanes --
even campers, hikers, Hunters.
With your help, I feel we can
get the word out to the masses
about this amazing new product
and help a lot of people
become better prepared
for the unexpected.
Thank you.
O'LEARY:
Now, you didn't tell us
how long the shelf life is
of this pill.
I have
a five-year shelf life.
You really haven't eaten
in eight days -- nothing?
Swear to God.
Just water and the pill?
This is nothing --
I went 17 days,
and they put me on a show
in Salt Lake City.
Four ladies were interviewing.
they kept saying,
"Oh, my gosh!
you must have lost weight!"
six, seven times.
did you lose weight?
First of all,
this is not a diet pill.
Yes, I've lost some weight.
And I think if you lose a little
weight to save your life,
that's a small price to pay.
But the point is, these women
were looking to you
and going,
"hmm. diet aid." right?
Well, I know
they were thinking that,
because there was
a 10,000 viewership on the show.
It was 98% women.
And after I said that,
we sold out.
We did $30,000 in sales.
HERJAVEC:
did you have one every day?
I take a pill for breakfast,
one for lunch, one for dinner,
and if I'm hungry at night,
I'll take a snack.
[ pops lips ]
[ laughs ]
Would you like to try it?
Yes!
Absolutely not. Could we see
the packaging, though?
Mark, "absolutely not"?
Absolutely not!
Okay. Here you go.
Thank you.
HERJAVEC:
Daryl, how many calories
are in each capsule?
There's a little bit of sugar
in each one,
but the calories are not there
so you can live on it.
The calories are there
to help drive the nutrients
right into your bloodstream.
All right.
so, I read this bottle.
mm-hmm.
And, basically,
everything in here
is like what's in some
of the vitamins that I take.
Isn't this just a vitamin?
There is a huge difference.
You know
when bears hibernate,
they go seven months
without food?
How do they do that?
Bears don't die.
They buy Life Caps.
[ laughter ]
when your body gets pure
nutrition but zero calories,
it feels free
to burn body fat.
I'm surviving right now
on my own body fat.
That's how bears hibernate.
We've created
a metabolic trigger
which allows the body to burn
its own fat for stored energy.
How much weight did you lose
in that eight days?
I burn a pound a day when I'm
doing this, and nothing else.
8 pounds?
JOHN: Let me ask you
something here.
At the end of the day, you want
a bunch of people to say,
"I want to just not eat
and take this instead."
No, that's not
what I'm going for at all.
Well, how do I make money?
well, then how do we
make money? Yeah.
Because I'm gonna buy
one pack. I don't need to
buy another for five years.
CUBAN: You guys seriously
are considering
looking at making money
from this nonsense?
I want to know --
I'm just -- I want to know
what he's thinking.
Daryl, are you
selling this today?
In five years,
we've done $440,000.
All you have to say --
"Hey, I took it for eight days,
lost a pound a day,"
and everybody goes nuts.
If this was real,
you would be telling us about
how you took it to doctors,
how you've had studies done.
I want to do
a clinical study.
I didn't have the money
to do it.
You have had
$100,000 in sales.
my doctor -- I went
and got a checkup on my 13th --
my doctor looked at it.
You are so full of crap.
You keep on going back
to all this nonsense, right?
Well, I haven't eaten
for eight days.
I have no crap in me --
trust me.
[ laughter ]
Daryl,
I want to buy you --
but, Daryl,
I have a big question.
Is this FDA-approved?
Of course not.
no supplement company wants --
the FDA does not approve dietary
supplements -- only drugs.
This is FDA 100% compliant.
Yeah,
because it's nothing!
You are
such a snake-oil salesperson.
If you do nothing,
it's FDA-compliant.
Mark, I challenge you
to go eight days without food!
Daryl, Daryl, you knew
that you'd run across
a guy like mark.
You had the sales.
you had the money.
Why didn't you get
some clinical tests done?
Well, I think
maybe it's time to do it.
I look at the last five years
as a test market.
O'LEARY:
so, I'm gonna suspend belief
for a second
and forget about
all the objections to this.
My biggest problem with it
is that I have to have
a few of these
sitting on the shelf
in case the zombies come.
[ laughs ]
The trouble is,
I'm not buying any more
until the zombies come,
so I just buy it once,
sits on my shelf
waiting for zombies.
That's no good.
That's the problem.
how do I make money?
That's the only problem?
Let's say this works.
why are we talking
about this?!
Look, I see why you came up
with this angle.
No one can contest it.
If this truly worked,
it'd be really, really easy
to take it to doctors
and do studies.
But instead, you come here
like a snake-oil salesperson
knowing that you're gonna prey
on everybody watching
the minute you said
you lose 1 pound per day
when you take this.
That's wrong.
I'm out, as Kevin says,
with prejudice.
Mark, I agree.
we backdoored the diet industry.
Like I said, I'm a musician.
I don't know
all the ins and outs.
What have you been doing
for five years?!
you know what, though?
He's a hustler.
I did a real-world study.
GREINER:
Whenever somebody is selling
something that you ingest,
you have to be
a really responsible person
and make sure that what
you're giving everybody is safe.
Doing the clinical trials
and the studies
and all of that beforehand
is really important.
You haven't done that.
I'm out.
Barbara,
can I explain one thing?
I'm not Barbara.
oh, excuse me -- Lori.
[ laughter ]
That mental thing
is not holding up.
Whoops. Yeah.
That mental thing
is not holding up.
HERJAVEC:
you know, the problem is,
people want a shortcut.
People don't want
to put the discipline in
it takes to eat healthy
and lose weight and so on.
So, a guy like you comes along,
and people see a shortcut.
And they don't look
behind the facade.
I think
it's irresponsible.
I'm out.
You know, the presentation
started off like steak.
It started to look like
filet mignon.
But, as the other sharks
pointed out,
no FDA approval, no research,
no clinical trials.
The filet mignon,
the steak,
just became
a rotten pack of baloney.
I'm out.
CUBAN:
And then there was one.
I'm just a guy
trying to scratch out a living.
I ask myself, can I make
any money investing in this?
And the answer is no.
I'm out.
STEVENETT:
I really appreciate all of you,
and I appreciate
what you're doing for people.
You're putting people to work,
helping entrepreneurs.
It's an honor to meet you all.
thank you.
Thank you.
CUBAN: He's such
a snake-oil salesperson.
He's gonna go anywhere
that there's an audience
and hope
that somebody says yes.
I get slimy
just thinking about him. Next!
NARRATOR: Next into the tank
is a mom from Provo, Utah,
with a stylish and functional
way to cover tiny feet.
Hi. My name
is Susan Petersen.
The name of my company
is Freshly Picked.
And I'm asking for $150,000
for 10%.
Freshly picked is
the world's best baby moccasin.
When my second child, Gus,
was born,
I looked everywhere
for this type of shoe.
Soft soles are
actually better for babies
that are learning to walk
because they can flex their toes
with every step,
and this promotes balance.
I couldn't find the shoe
that I was looking for,
so I decided to try my hand
at making one.
I had a bag of scrap leather
that I'd gotten
from a garage sale,
and I taught myself how to sew.
I worked through
six different designs
until I landed on one
that fit the bill.
Let me show you
how amazing my moccasins are.
These are gonna remind you
of your days on the track.
GREINER: Adorable.
Stay golden.
Oh, thank you.
they're so cute.
Thank you.
'cause I like your heart.
And for your team.
HERJAVEC:
they're beautiful.
Yeah, really cute.
Where do you make these?
I started out making these
all by myself.
Two years ago, I hired
a local girl to help me,
and then we also get them made
in California, as well.
HERJAVEC: Susan,
how do you sell them today?
Strictly through
our e-commerce site.
And what are
your sales?
$500,000.
$500,000?!
That's a big number.
this year.
GREINER: Wow!
wow!
O'LEARY: This year?
Good for you.
Susan, what's your profit
on the $500,000?
$120,000.
How many pairs is the most
active buyer buying from you?
Okay,
that's a good question.
$500,000?!
All my questions are good,
Susan.
That's why they call me
"Mr. Wonderful."
Kevin, your face
is on my pillow at night.
I've gone to bed --
yeah!
I love you.
whoa!
Keep it up,
I'll drop the royalty rate.
All right.
answer that question, please.
PETERSEN: Okay, wait.
So, out of all of our customers
that have made one purchase,
50% of them have come back
and bought
at least three more times.
That's very impressive.
Can a baby easily
just pull it off?
No. That's the thing.
The elastic keeps it
around their ankle.
So, Susan,
$500,000 in sales.
Tell me how much money
you've put into the company
when you started.
So, when I first started,
I didn't have any money.
My husband was in school,
and we were really, really poor.
My brother owns
a window-installation business,
and so I convinced him
one summer
to give me all the old windows
he took out.
And I spent the whole summer
out there during that time
in the heat banging the glass
out of those windows,
'cause they're aluminum-frame.
I took those frames
to the scrapyard
at the end of the summer,
and I got $200.
And I was able to buy
one hide of leather,
which makes
about 40 moccasins.
That's really great.
And then I just continually
put it back in.
And that's why we had
kind of a slow start.
That literally
is the best story
to start a company
I've ever heard.
How much
do these sell for?
I don't think
we got a price point.
$60 retail.
$60 a pair?
60 bucks?
uh-huh.
And what do you
make them for?
We're at about $17,
'cause we're still domestic.
What's the projection
for next year?
I think with
just my social media alone,
I can do
between $2- and $3 million.
That's a lot
of baby shoes.
I am gaining about 1,500 new
followers on Instagram a week,
and we've found that
about 10% of our Instagram buy.
And do you have retailers
that are customers?
Any brick and mortar?
We have a lot of retailers
that are interested,
but I can't keep up
with the demand.
I need the money
to make a big order overseas.
This next year,
my vision for the company
is to start
moving into retail.
I'm just wondering --
how in love with retail are you?
Because it's a very tough
business on the inventory side.
I really -- I want to --
I want to build
a big, big, big company.
But you want to make money.
you're right.
Retail's like a siren
on an ancient ship,
drawing the sailors towards her
and then drowning them.
That's what happens.
it's true.
And I've seen it happen
many, many times.
They take your capital.
They put your product
in the store.
they get paid, plus 30 days.
Susan, let me just say --
your story
of taking the windows
and pulling out the aluminum
should be
in every business book,
in every entrepreneur's guide.
You personify
the American dream
of saying,
"get off my butt,
and let's go out there
and get it done."
thank you, mark.
Now, that said, right,
I'm not the guy
for the baby-shoes world.
I'd be learning from you more
than you'd be learning from me.
I can't respect you enough,
but I have to say I'm out.
Okay.
So, Susan, like mark said,
very impressive.
I have a saying
that I always tell people --
"sales trumps all."
I mean, wow!
$500,000 --
you got it going on.
I just -- I can't add anything
to the baby-shoe business.
I don't think
I'm the right partner for you.
I'm out.
You have what it takes
to make a great business
and to run your business.
I actually think that
you'll be better on your own.
So, for that reason,
I'm out.
How many pairs do you think
you're gonna sell in a year?
Next year?
yeah.
Between 25,000 to 30,000.
So, if you feel
you're gonna do that --
which is more than awesome,
it's amazing --
why do you feel
you need the $150,000?
Why take on a partner?
Well,
I haven't been to school.
This is my first business,
and I have been burned
a couple times.
And I really --
I -- I love advice.
No one ever
has to do the work for me.
As shown, I will do it.
But I need help
with manufacturing.
That's a big one for me.
I don't want
10% of a company.
That's just -- it doesn't
get me up in the morning.
I mean,
that's just not enough
for all the headaches
you're gonna be.
I -- I am not a headache.
Business is always
full of headaches. Trust me.
But you have
high margins.
So, I'm gonna set up
a rather crafty way of doing it.
You have to get $150,000,
and in this deal,
I need this guy
more than he needs me.
But I bring a lot
to the table
in terms of making you
bigger than you are.
I'll give you $75,000,
and the way I would structure it
is -- no equity.
Don't want any.
I want a royalty.
I'd like to do a royalty
of 7%
until my $75,000 comes back,
and then drop it down to 5%.
And you can well afford that,
actually.
You have to give her
$150,000, kev.
No, but I only have $75,000,
unfortunately.
I wonder
if anybody else has $75,000.
So, that means, Daymond,
you have to give her $75,000.
NARRATOR:
three sharks are out.
Susan has a partial offer
from Kevin
but needs Daymond
to join in on the offer.
Susan, I say I give you
the $150,000 for 25%
and we tell this bozo
to take a walk.
Ooh.
25%.
wow. That's expensive.
I'm 25% of a partnership
with you,
and I'll help you
with everything.
That's a lot of equity.
This is a real debate
for you, now.
It really is.
no, it's not.
Kevin, I really thank you
for your offer, but I think
at this point in my business,
where I want to grow to,
I don't think it's smart
for me to give you 7%.
What would you give me
if I kept my equity at zero?
Tell him to take a walk
and let's do this.
I would give you a kiss.
Ohh!
yeah!
what?!
That -- that is cheap.
that's cheap.
that's what's in it for me --
a kiss?
Tell him to take a walk.
why are you not dealing
with Daymond?
Susan, why are you
not dealing with Daymond?
I -- I -- I was gonna --
I -- Daymond.
I -- you're actually --
you're my dream shark.
Will you do $150,000
for 20%?
I'm gonna give you
the respect of who you are
because of what you've done
and what you've accomplished.
I normally would want 1/3.
I would like to stay
at 25%.
So, $150,000 for 25%
values my company at $600,000,
which is almost
what I've done this year.
I think next month,
I'll hit that mark.
But you're
my dream investor.
It's six times your profits.
it's six times your profit.
It's not -- it's not what
I'm valuing your company at.
Yeah.
it's what
I'm valuing my time at.
'cause when you put in
the valuation,
if we were
just purely doing valuation,
that means
I just write you $150,000
and I look in my mailbox every
quarter and I don't help you.
Susan,
one thing, though.
yes.
When you sell the company
one day for $100 million,
you're gonna cry
on my pillow
for the $25 million
you're gonna give him.
Kevin, I love you,
but I don't think
I can give away
any percentage of my profit.
Susan, $150,000, 25%
from Daymond.
You got to make
a decision.
When I go to New York next time,
can I come see your office?
You will have a space
in my office.
How about that?
we have a deal.
Yay!
All right.
I love it.
you are a tough cookie.
GREINER:
Nice deal. Congrats, Susan.
I'm so excited
to work with you!
Thank you for letting me be
a part of your dream.
This is amazing.
thank you.
Congrats.
Great job, Susan.
Thank you.
Great deal.
All right.
I liked that one.
Good job.
PETERSEN: I'm really excited
to work with Daymond
because he knows manufacturing,
he knows retail.
He's just
the perfect combination for me.
It's gonna be
a beautiful marriage.